la parole est maintenant monsieur marc
fesneau du groupe mouvement démocrate et
apparentés de l'assemblée nationale vous
avez la parole monsieur finaux pour 10
minutes maximum
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires chers
collègues
c'est un jour solennel que celui où le
président de la république convoquant le
congrès à versailles s'adresse à
l'ensemble des parlementaires et à
travers eux au peuple français
la gravité du lieu et du moment doit
nous inciter à prendre la mesure de ce
qui nous réunit
le président de la république a choisi
de s'exprimer devant l'ensemble des
hommes et des femmes que les français
par l'exercice de leurs droits de
citoyens ont voulu investir des pouvoirs
qui sont ceux de la nation tout entière
dans le seul but de répondre aux défis
qui se posent à notre pays il a souhaité
présenter devant le parlement les
grandes lignes de son action et définir
le sens et le cap qu'il souhaite donner
la solennité de l'instant nous impose
donc à tous députés et sénateurs un
devoir de responsabilité responsabilité
du rôle qu'il est désormais le nôtre
face au français qui attendent de leurs
représentants et de ceux qui les
gouvernent qu'il réponde de manière
déterminée et efficace aux problèmes de
notre temps et nous savons combien ils
sont nombreux et combien ils sont lourds
dans la situation n'a cessé de se
dégrader au cours des dernières
décennies
nourrissant la colère d'une grande part
de notre peuple qui est las d'attendre
des résultats responsabilité surtout
quand on compte que nous aurons
collectivement aaron à rendre de notre
action à la fin de notre mandat
ne doutons pas que les français sauront
nous rappeler nos deux à nos devoirs et
à nos engagements et à être aussi
implacable avec nous si nous devions
faillir qu'ils auront été enthousiaste a
souhaité un profond changement pour le
pays
les campagnes qui s'achève ont laissé un
goût amer à tous ceux qui chérissent
l'action politique
elles ont vu pour la campagne
présidentielle tout d'abord accédé au
deuxième tour et pour le deuxième fois
une candidate issue des extrêmes et pour
la campagne des législatives ensuite les
citoyens se détournent est largement
d'un scrutin pourtant si cruciale disons
le simplement la reconquête des coeurs
et de l'attention des français ne se
fera que par l'obtention de résultats
nets
et durable qui garantiront l'avenir de
notre pays et par le rétablissement de
la confiance entre les représentants du
peuple que nous sommes et les citoyens
cette responsabilité historique le
groupe modem depuis longtemps investi
sur ce sujet en temps l'assumer
pleinement au sein de la majorité
vous vous conduisez monsieur le premier
ministre est aux côtés du président de
la république la majorité que nous
formons veut être au service des
français et nous reconnaissons
parfaitement dans le cadre proposé par
le chef de l'état depuis le début de son
mandat et exprimer ce jour devant le
congrès je le dis et je là si mon nom de
mon groupe
aujourd'hui notre responsabilité de
parlementaires et de permettre au
gouvernement de mettre en oeuvre le plus
tôt possible
les propositions du candidat emmanuel
macron que les français ont placé en
tête du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avant de les lire par la
suite et a donc pour nous simplement la
volonté d'agir et d'agir vite pour que
les français qui par deux fois en
conscience et en toute liberté
on fait les choix de réforme que la
majorité portent puisse voir se réaliser
les changements qu'ils attendent depuis
si longtemps la ligne sur laquelle nous
nous engageons est une ligne de crête
car jamais dans notre histoire récente
sans doute la défiance n'a été aussi
grande vis-à-vis du monde politique
nous sommes tous les porte voix du
peuple français nous devons nous vous
souvenir que si nous en avons tous nous
avons tous une terre d'élection nous à
son monsieur moins individuellement une
part de la souveraineté de tout un
peuple de ses espoirs que nous soyons de
la majorité comme de l'opposition
depuis longtemps nous avons identifié ce
mal qui ronge notre démocratie qui
détache peu à peu les citoyens de leurs
élus l'action résolue des élus du
mouvement démocrate en faveur d'un
rapprochement des citoyens avec leur
institution émane de notre volonté de
rendre notre démocratie plus
représentatives et plus ouverte
ainsi la loi pour la confiance dans
notre vie démocratique va dans le sens
d'un renforcement de nos institutions
d'une amélioration de l'efficacité de
notre fonctionnement et d'une meilleure
réponse aux exigences du temps le non
cumul des mandats y compris dans la
durée l'impératif d'exemplarité des élus
l'encadrement renforcé de nos activités
tout cela doit permettre de ramener la
confiance chez nos concitoyens
il s'agit de la condition même de la
légitimité de la parole et de l'action
politique sans quoi aucune réforme
durable ne sera possible
l'abstention toujours plus forte à
chaque élection
en plus nécessaire une telle réforme et
les autres réformes institutionnelles
annoncées aujourd'hui par le président
de la république vont qui est garante de
nos institutions vont y concourir ainsi
la constitution d'une juste
représentation de toutes les forces
politiques dont nous a semblé de la
proportionnelle pour garantir aux
français leur plus juste et plus
équitable représentation est posée c'est
une question centrale pour notre vie et
pour notre respiration démocratique
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires vous savez
notre peuple ne se retrouvent et ne se
réunit jamais mieux qu autour d'idéaux
autour d'un grand dessein et d'une
vision les français connaissent toute la
profondeur des temps et de l'histoire
ils savent la portée de notre message
universel qui depuis toujours fait de
lui un peuple soucieux des autres quand
ses représentants ne sont pas à la
hauteur de cette histoire c'est toute la
france qui se perd et son message qui
s'affaiblit quant au contraire ils le
sont et en premier lieu le chef de
l'état l'unité le rayonnement
redeviennent possible le président de la
république s'inscrit pleinement et de
plain pied dans cette volonté de
restaurer dans notre pays on ce qu'il a
de si spécifique dans son fonctionnement
et en même temps de 6 universelle en
deux mois à peine on perçoit la
réaffirmation des positions
traditionnelles de la france que ce soit
dernièrement au g7 sur les enjeux
économiques mon dieu où concernant
l'enjeu capital du monde du climat ou
bien encore sur celui de la sécurité la
voix de la france est devenue plus
lisible en europe aussi nous nous
réjouissons de voir la france renoué
avec l'idéal et le projet originel
européens y compris dans le lien
indéfectible que nous avons avec
l'allemagne le président de la
république a su nouer ce dialogue
nouveau être les français avec la france
et avec nos partenaires internationaux
tout reste à faire bien entendu mais
nous le sentons partout dans le
territoire plus que jamais la france en
prêt à bouger a changé attentes et elle
attend désormais que nous soyons au
rendez-vous de l'espérance qui s'élevait
ce printemps elle attend que par nos
actes notre capacité de dialogue et
notre écoute nous réformions elle attend
elle espère peut-être surtout de
retrouver la confiance en ceux qui la
gouvernent et retrouver la confiance en
elle-même cet élan chers collègues il
nous faut le soutenir hardiment avec la
lucilie avec lucidité avec exigence et
avec toute la force du profond
renouvellement qui s'est opéré ces
derniers mois et cette volonté que
beaucoup d'entre nous incarne sur ses
bancs sur le premier ministre ce n'est
pas se payer de mots que de cons
sidéré votre action comme porteuse
porteuse d'une nouvelle ambition pour la
france
la voix de la france est attendu écouter
et nous nous réjouissons qu'elle le soit
de la paix soit celle de la tolérance du
dialogue de l'ouverture de l'idéal de
liberté de ces valeurs européennes et
humaniste qui nous sont chères votre
action pourra s'appuyer sur les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle et du groupe au nom
duquel je m'exprime aujourd'hui l'esprit
de conquête des mots mêmes du président
de la république parle à l'imaginaire de
notre pays et fondent notre destin
commun c'est un tel souffle dans notre
pays a besoin
l'élection d' emmanuel macron la
constitution d'une majorité claire
autour de vous monsieur le premier
ministre suscite espoirs et attentes
à nous d'être désormais au rendez vous
fixé avec le peuple français et que le
président de la république est venu
exprimer et rappeler cet après midi à
notre congrès celui de nous confronter
au réel pour mieux pouvoir servi notre
idéal celui d'institutions moderniser
lisible et qui permette le débat et la
vie démocratique
celui enfin d'un pays fier de lui et sûr
de lui même et qui parle au reste du
monde
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]